Millennials is warning everyone welcome
back to the morning chose the Millennial
morning show today's Tuesday July 25th I
want to say that doesn't sign I've known
for about a week that tired path was
coming on the 24th right so don't even
pretend like you don't know the date
yeah you have an extra pep in your step
this morning well it's actually because
I went to bed at 10:30 but we can we can
we can I know it I think it's because
today's the Darracq of it all so I've
been obsessed with Deric path since he
first came on The Bachelor I just think
he's the most underrated person in the
franchise he had a brief misstep when he
decided to getting a chiller mocha but I
can look past that he is here today
because I didn't even know that he lived
in New York did you know that I know and
she's like here being a businessman
special wait he's up being like a thirst
monster general like here's a job right
which is pretty cool we'll find out
about it when we sit down with him
there's a lot that's gonna go down when
we sit down with him and we're just
really excited I'm gonna excited for my
sister because like it's such a big day
for her and just to see the look of love
on your face the likes of which I
haven't seen like since your wedding so
it's you know just some irony for you
somewhat coincidence for you some what's
really strange is today is July 24th
they're expected feathers on the morning
toast and also it's the week that
Claudia sent her ring to the shop I
didn't send it to the shop
I was going jewelry shopping at
Stephanie Gottlieb punch really my kind
of honor works there and she was like
making me try on like a million things
and then she showed me that my
engagement ring is bent she was like she
lived lift-away it so I'm like no she's
like that really only happens when
you're like lifting heavy things I'm
like well I'm just like an animal who
probably been to my ring just by
accident so it's being reset because I
like broke it so coincidentally she is
not wearing her ring today
strangely enough neither am i but this
isn't about yeah weird this isn't about
me and Jackie's I was like oh my god I
never take off my ring watch wearing it
I started taking it off for when I sleep
because people say that I shed him when
I work out because people cuz I'm finish
it and it will Bend
Oh sleeping in the ring is weird yeah I
never bothered me before but now it's
like oh it's nice no I got my fingers
when my ring is on I can't relax do you
know any mean when I have any jewelry on
besides like this tiny little necklace I
feel like I'm at work do you know what I
mean you know it's really truly be
relaxed in your own home without wearing
rings
don't know how people like wear rings
recreationally just anyone a ton and use
ring jargon in everyday life yeah a ton
and stack them yeah they'd one like
Psychopaths I'm gonna help mini a mini
one on their nails Psychopaths
that's wild you guys but anyways we have
hopefully a great show for you today
I went to extraordinary lengths to not
talk about Pete and Arianna today even
though if you a number of things happen
between the like in the end nothing
really happened so like to talk about it
we just be talking in circles about
nothing basically he just deleted all
the pictures on his Instagram because he
can't take the negativity from the
internet like get in line bro right same
like I kind of understood the decision I
thought it was extreme to delete all the
pictures like you already went through
here we're hosting and maybe just like
slow down on the posting but you know
what's so interesting is that like Pete
and Ariana like the media like loves
them like everyone loves them so like
even someone who's like being adored by
the media gets so much negativity that
it's like overbearing like imagine
getting negative media attention but
just think about that play button and
then he'll be so grateful and you'll
reinstall your Instagram account like
today right so anyways I didn't follow
him not a loss for me and things are
going really well between them and I
guess yeah she has a new album coming
out that she's promoting but not
promoting in the way that she used to
promote and then her fans were like oh
my god her Twitter it's like so shady
she's like always like getting into like
legit arguments with her fans cuz like
she doesn't technically do press anymore
like when she's releasing an album like
she doesn't go on like Jimmy Fallon like
most artists do like in the time that
they're like the week before their
albums coming out and a lot of the fans
were like pissy about it and she was
like honest I just hate doing it it's
like makes me insane and like leave me
alone
and they think she's reaches this stage
in her career where she doesn't have to
I lock Taylor Swift who will never give
another interview probably ever again
unless it's like my third right but
unless it's on her turf ya know like
when she got that when she interviewed
that woman songwriter in Harper's Bazaar
that was strange
yes yes exactly a very strange unless
it's on her turf imagine being so famous
like you don't need GMA like even super
famous people go on GMA I bet imagine
being so famous like you never will go
on GMA again that's crazy I mean they're
gonna have to wake up at those guys
you're right that's true what about time
shows
so I don't know I feel like she's
definitely a morning person but like her
shows go till 11:00 so like she doesn't
eat sleep you know yeah crazy well she
plays till 10:45 she probably like has a
drink after where it's like with the
dancers and then gets home which is like
a 30 minute ride she's gotten dead
before midnight no but I mean she's not
like that much of a granny granny yeah
totally
yeah she definitely wakes up like 9m
she's ever gonna make some of the same
time every day like it's the same
breakfast when just she needs for
breakfast like granola oatmeal yeah or
like yogurt cream yogurt she totally
i'ma Taylor balanced breakfast I get one
orange juice of fruit bowl yeah and so
of course some morning toast
Oh which speaking of here the best five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast first up very exciting
news one direction sparked or rumors and
reunion rumors when tickets were
uploaded to Ticketmaster for a 2022 one
direction toward that were immediately
taken down oh they were yeah it was I
that Dan spotted it you can't get
anything past the director they've
Google Alerts left right in the center
I follow this One Direction fan account
that does like you videos of all the
guys but then also that gives updates
and they posted it it was at a tea HOD
stadium which I don't know where that is
but it's definitely in Europe and I just
think like wow what a world
it was in Australia Australia it would
be for 2020 which is a year and a half
gives everyone time to wrap up their
personal like Harry's done with the tour
I don't know about it I don't think they
once and to be a part of it and I
actually recently heard from someone
like in the biz that Zayn won't perform
live anymore why because there was a lot
of speculation that he was gonna be a
guest at Taylor Swift's show because he
was in town
Gigi went to the show and they have a
song together um and I was talking with
someone about and they were like no he
does not perform live I mean this it's
not totally surprising no but like in
one direction he performed live like
every day and also like the album that
they did without him was just as great
as the ones before totally like he's
lost it does not make or break one
Direction's Harry does yeah and if the
four of them go back together I'll be
super excited like if it's the five of
them
I have a question for you say they only
they get back together in 2020 one night
oniy at only at Etihad Stadium in Dover
instead we're going we're going I've
been wanting to there's a trillion
toasters group because there was a girl
on my show in Denver who told me about
it Wow she had just moved from Australia
will be so our lips are sealed
totally we'll have to join them I feel
like you could only go to Australia
either I'm the witness protect the
me to Australia seems great no it seems
like so cosmopolitan the flight like me
like that's the only thing he does you
know my dad asked us to be in first
class I'm like it's literally $10,000
but in first class it's not good there's
no way around it really unless the
points guy how to get a good fun maybe
we like go somewhere for a while in LA
and then it's like six hours less that's
still nothing like it's just when t
four-hour flight yeah it's still an
18-hour flight you know I don't think I
would go crazy and we need to go to like
Israel or somewhere yeah like half away
torture maybe we won't go I don't think
I can play the tour to the States or why
don't they do it in London their
hometown that's a world I just mother I
just made that up but that's the one
Sadie I'm not they're not gonna do a
one-night-only
that would be crazy though that would be
crazy that would be like the stuff of
legends that juice Andy will be writing
about in 50 years yes
did you see some stats were released
about Harry Styles tour and he like
donated over a million dollars to
charity from his tour no I didn't think
that's so cute I love him that's so
sweet
with charity Deana um it said it but I
don't recall I believe it was something
in the LGBTQ circle but I'm not sure
that's really really sweet
yeah and even like say it himself I feel
like there's just something so Shaddai
about celebrities for like post pictures
of themselves at with like the Ryan
Seacrest foundation at hospitals you
know II mean it's like totally you're
doing it for the wrong reasons like tail
it like nobody knows but like literally
every city teller ghost you're she goes
to a Children's Hospital donates money
like spent time I pick it gives tickets
and like nobody knows about it like
that's how you know she's doing it for
the right reason and that's what these
like anonymous charity is the best
charity yeah I don't know when people
are just like blasting all over their
Instagram they went to a Children's
Hospital I'm like first of all like
don't blow up these kids spots like
putting pictures of them on the internet
when they're not at their best and just
like just stop like some things can be
like sacred I
I agree just a thought um anyways that's
really exciting this one direction news
yeah but 2020 is so far away no it's not
it's halfway through 2018 it's a year
and a half okay you're gonna have till
January 20 honey there's no way that
it's January right let's check you later
first so actually this show would be on
December 31st 2020 so it's in - it's in
three years no it's in two years two and
a half two and a half yeah that's
forever
oh [ __ ] like I guess I'll be 28 I
thought I was 30 yeah no oh because I'm
30 years old at a One Direction concert
I'll be out and shoot me
maybe I'll be uh expecting the future a
little a little path a sibling for CEO
except there'll be step siblings cuz
regularly alright Co Saffir baby path
that's true it's true okay fine Claudia
Pat okay what's next
are you okay bring you out I'm not ready
not ready we need to I need to like slap
in my face and I see HOD Stadium is in
Manchester no it says in Melbourne
someone just message that I think Etihad
Stadium in Melbourne Australia
maybe capital SM is wrong but that's my
source here okay so eat my ass okay okay
now the rest of our stories today are
just well-rounded because I just can't
enchant with the celebrity Robin I know
know what I can't keep talking about the
same things and it's like I just started
to listen to myself when I talk to me
just sounds so like on it you keep it
like I went to NYU for Christ's sake
look let's talk about the change to good
use yeah okay I don't have anything
about climate change today but last
night someone told me there's a
hurricane coming on Wednesday and then I
might have like spread that around even
though so unfounded so today I googled
like let me do the hurricane story and
there's no hurricane happening it's just
rain you know people are out here like
just spreading lies that's why it's so
important to watch the morning chess
where you get well well-rounded facts
like people just tell me stuff on the
internet and like I just believe it
look at the Etihad Stadium is in
Manchester no look I just believe it's
right found that like I'm wrong and I
told someone they were so gonna be a
hurricane I'm one thing they started to
move their flight meanwhile there's no
hurricane no I have a flight on Friday
and I just got upgraded to first class
for free so like I cannot have a
hurricane [ __ ] that up for me no but
Friday should be okay technically to
fake her because I'm going to Phoenix
this
hurricane is coming on Wednesday I was
told that the show after I mentioned it
obviously on the morning toast the most
influential morning show in morning news
almost sold out I believe there's like
30 tickets left all the VIP is sold out
sorry
you can get a ga ticket only $25 and
it's gonna be really hot so you should
go that sounds nice what's the
temperature there um hot are you gonna
go to here by Chrissy okay so I'm simply
gonna make a few in my monologue I
always like to do like local jokes you
know well it's Lok's like in Denver I
was talking about the pot and st. Louis
I was talking about how Carrie Bradshaw
ruins st. Louis meet me in st. Louis you
know um and I was definitely gonna talk
about here by Christie in my Phoenix
monologue okay but you should go to her
I know
oisin but I'm over there you're like art
scale they're like pretty close I think
they're like the same well don't you
always get like local artisan in hair
and makeup I do I do I also you have to
get a picture I've heard of that wall I
do but like all for nothing hair is like
out of control like I don't even think I
would like it I think well first of all
doesn't it's it's not about that right
you need to get a picture in front of
that wall you're gonna leave the salon
blonde with like literally like crazy
yeah and like a huge poof in the magic
her hair is out of control she makes
those girls with nuts know they they
look good they look like just like
fairies yeah just walking amongst us so
she makes the hair look so big that the
body looks tiny so she'll have to make
my hair like three times I think you
have her dream hair because extensions
the girl's hair look like yours that's
true you need one of her big braids yeah
and I'm sure there are a lot of fair by
sissies and Phoenix that are inspired by
her work you know we had a girl
um who did our makeup in Nashville she
who's between Nashville and Phoenix and
she like works with hair by Chrissy it's
really remarkable that's just like this
Oh Jackie they said she's in Gilbert
it's not even close so it's really
remarkable that this hairdresser in
Gilbert has really made a name for
herself where celebrities like flies are
in Gilbert before they go on their trip
to Mexico like it's really amazing good
for her good for her honestly it's the
drew I feel like she could do amazing
things to my hair like she would need to
get extensions for me look that a show
about her salon like might be
interesting
might be it just depends on her
personnel right and like the staff right
okay I'm I'm but their shows that staffs
are like over I'm like people are really
trying to recreate the magic that is men
are from pearls and it's just like
gonna happen no it's not gonna happen
but I actually had a really good idea
for a show
randomly that like revolves should have
a reality show 100% right and like every
all their trips like I'm sure there's so
much interesting drums yeah or they can
make it up no everyone's beautiful yeah
everyone's come true and even the girls
that work for them look like revolved
girls they have like a hundred thousand
followers it's a great idea it's a great
idea it should be on a for sure yeah
make [ __ ] like that's the real version
of so Cosmo know so cosmos like the
dumbest show ever and it's so bad it's
not they didn't even get a second season
anime there's anything I think honestly
yet only having one season it's worse
than having no show at all oh for sure
it's so Glenn like he is the queen of a
one season shows one season wonders yeah
they literally like make shitty reality
shows that last for one season hopefully
berry Cavallari doesn't follow it follow
in today but it definitely will I'm not
hearing good things I'm not hearing good
things but I think like if they get
season 2 they'll have an opportunity to
sort of to mix it up like we need
Kristin's real life like these videos
are - it's the same thing with - Styles
at Courtney and whatever would be in it
for like literally ten seconds right and
like I don't expect Kristen put her kids
on camera and honestly I wouldn't like
expect this show to be made much better
by the fact that there's kids on it but
like warmer house more some real life
stuff her real friends not these hired
help yeah yeah totally
okay anyways this next story is just in
some media industry world news you know
jobs of course the oh it's not about
jobs um and even though we reported some
really good news about jobs apparently a
trunk laid off the New York Daily News
entire social media team what's what's
at wrong I guess from reading it again
it sounds like the company that
maintenance bought Daily News
oh but um later oh sure like the bosses
the bosses laid off the New York Daily
News entire social media team so they
got revenge via gif this is hilarious
you guys on Monday staffers at the New
York Daily News received an email
informing them that its parent company
trunk would be letting off half of the
editorial team trunk also plans to
direct what remains of the newsroom to
shift its focus to breaking news the
email which was obtained by CNN read in
part quote we know our readers look to
us for a unique point of view and we
believe these topics offer our best
opportunity to direct
differentiate our reporting we will of
course continue to cover local news
sports and other events but our approach
will evolve as we adapt to our current
environment okay you're all fired
yeah anyways the social media team got
the boot but before they laughed they
tweeted some gifts it was like John
Travolta oh my god that's so fun thank
you John Travolta from pulp fiction like
really nothing like where to go never go
and then another one from Charleston has
Sue's character from Planet of the Apes
it's a madhouse oh my god that's so
funny I have three two things to say one
it's always sad when people get laid off
like it should not happen to like a
media company laying off their social
media it's just proof that the daily
news is not in tune with what's
necessary look I think that the daily
news could use five more social media
managers and five less like phirni lists
who write about like things going on in
Brooklyn do you know what I mean like
journalists who like went to college
like sorry they're useless do you need a
social media team obviously your
company's failing you were further
proving why the company's failing by
cutting your social media team and the
company's only gonna fail even more
right and I like Mike we do those like
granola BuzzFeed writers you got and
keep and losing your social media step
that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard
yeah we gotta get in there anyways the
gyms like they could have posted much
worse stuff so like this is actually
really funny and like what do you expect
when you lay off your whole social media
team except I works in social media for
a very long time and I would never have
done oh my god no but like honestly good
for these girl I'm assuming its girls
but good family I actually don't think
it's gross because girls would have done
like different gifts totally but like
social media managers are always girls I
don't know it's very mixed
yeah no it's just this is hilarious I
mean it's said that people got laid off
but like it's just so funny because
obviously like the irony and that's
article is like what people are missing
is like the company's not doing well so
they had to layoff people but they're
laying off the people that they probably
might need most who could probably house
in for that and a chance and they're
keeping like these old-school
journalists who are just like nasty and
have no lives like they need to go yeah
so some you have to evolve
yeah that's so funny but I mean media is
just a revolving doors yeah don't let
the door hit you where the good Lord
split you I've been watching Hannah
Montana and listening clearly Hannah
and it is just so funny how my tennis
season 4 is strange and like Lily's
living with her and it's weird and it's
like her and Oliver kiss the first
episode where they announced that they
were together but them in the season
finale they don't show them kissing
because like the kiss thing is weird
they have like the bellhop cover up the
kiss but it's like we've seen them kiss
and by the way these people are like 25
yeah no it's not about the people it's
about the viewers and also it's really
getting hard for me I watch descendants
all weekend I watched you kind of
Montana now and it's really getting hard
for me to watch this stuff like knowing
what goes on behind the scenes and the
people who make these shows like no one
is not agreed 100% but in the defense of
destiny I haven't read crazy things
about Disney I've read it about
Nickelodeon and like other like
low-level casting couch like kids things
but Disney has pretty much stayed clean
from what I've read but I just feel like
if you're working with kids yeah it's
bad as a reason there's been speculation
like on the internet never anything
concrete about Kenny Ortega I refuse to
believe that he's a bad guy but like he
has such a nice life he's like a really
cute family and a cute husband and like
the kids who worked with him only have
good things to say I always go to bat
for it and him in the comment and they
always post pictures with him like I
don't see anyone doing that with John
Schneider do you know what I mean
no I don't I did the Hannah Montana best
of both worlds story like yeah I just
don't think you could be a monster and
do that I know Disney is just like um
too big of a company to be so like it
and like they're like a wholesome
company and they're like ABC ESPN like
eight I bet I guess volume is Viacom
provide comm is like MTV vh1 they're not
as wholesome do you know what I mean
I don't know Claud and just for right
now I'm I'm believing that Disney is
good and there's so few good things left
in the world I'll just let me have this
okay okay Hannah Montana is good yeah
and because Billy Ray wasn't around like
I really don't think that was going on
that's what um that's what one of the
blinds there that four part series where
we haven't figured out who it is yet the
girl was like if you go anywhere without
your parent like you are just like
there's so much trouble like you're in
danger but going with you're going with
your parent is like a surefire way to a
not get jobs but to be like also
knocking Austin right but maybe you'll
get the job like if you're really
directed if you get the less chance yeah
so you have to shine more what a
disgusting world we live in I'm just
like I'm always I
I never cease to be amazed by the
disgustingness that we reach you know
yeah new levels and we're always
reaching new levels yes it's quite
astonishing okay next story kind of
piggybacking off of the story from
yesterday this seems to be a trend but
pepperidge farm is issuing a recall for
3.3 million packages of goldfish
crackers what is with over salmonella
contamination fears so what's going on
you guys like no one's reporting
salmonella but everyone's worried that
it's contaminated I see a certain member
in my dream and I'm not gonna say
because it's so weird it doesn't have to
do with dairy no doesn't have to do with
salmonella
no but like I just remembered it I don't
know why was a triggered by something he
said and now I'm feeling shame for the
weird dream that I had well now you know
I am NOT you know just know too long
didn't I'm not I'm not doing summarize
cliffnotes no keep going cliff no no
it's really weird I don't wanna talk
about it go give me one name of the
person in the dream it wasn't it wasn't
anyone we know it was just like I mean
like my friends in high school right now
but like it wasn't like a slippery or
anything I swear okay the company on
Monday took the action after one of its
ingredient suppliers notified it the
whey powder used in seasoning maybe
because this is the same as roots you
guys leaving oh so I guess Ritz and
Pepperidge Farm and Ritz both have the
same distributor for that powder because
they didn't have the issue in their
factory it was like an ingredient that
they used so I guess they both are now
to use it yes so pepperidge farm is
owned by Campbell Soup and Ritz crackers
are owned by Mondelez global and it
seems like these two heavy hitters just
can't get the right way powder I feel
like we need to go to Kauai powder
factory yeah sniff it out right
something's going on yeah I wanna I want
a thorough investigation this is sort of
like Kingsman like this could be a plot
like they're poisoning the Hawaii powder
so like and these are like kids foods
like someone who hates kids I know who's
doing it mate Dan Schneider no but then
like whose feet is he gonna sniff true
maybe the Hawaii powders contaminated to
the feet can you smell oh yeah cuz
you're sick you're sweating so much and
you're firing and he's knocking
door-to-door to the recall ha ha ha
that's enough
it is money oh my god that's a
cerebellum jokes that pedophilia it's
okay we're not joking about p2p I work
for joking about food yes which is funny
do you think you have any fetishes or
should I say fetish I I think I
definitely have like a makeup fetish
okay that's not it's not a hobby
it's like a disgusting obsession that I
can't stop thinking about oh I do what
like puppy pit bulls oh well I can think
about like my on strangers face says I'm
like pop it [ __ ] like try me
I like once a week before about I'll
watch doctrine Baba partly catch up on I
never have watched one of those videos
to completion
they're so good like that's a real
fetish oh my god I feel you don't think
I have anything like that I'm just like
look I can't look been dead shot in the
face without being like let me get that
blackhead oh my god I'm so that was I
don't even touch my back heads they look
like freckles how nice for you until I
take my makeup off and they're gonna
sign in Margo's looking at my face
saying really I'm just obsessed like I
analyze people's faces like like you
know I'm like a spy and when I wear
glasses instead of like looking at their
information they literally scan their
face for blackheads and pimples that are
ready to go that's crazy
no I know it's the first thing I think
when I see people and if I'm comfortable
with them I would literally ask about it
that's like dana has an obsession with
moles oh my god that's disgusting that
was not in the same way that you're
obsessed but like she if you if you name
anyone that she's ever met you tell you
about her it's crazy I like literally
despise moles I hate the word mole
always talking about most of it like
we'll be like oh do you remember so into
you saying yeah the one with the mole on
his eye oh man that's so disgusting no
it's so crazy
I also we need to talk to Dana she's
just so yeah we're gonna do a patriotic
aside with Dana so yeah we're gonna get
some answers for you guys I forgot
that's probably the weirdest thing about
her and there are a lot of weird things
that is so gross I'm so grossed out I
know that's me to say like I'm just so
burst out by people's moles and like
they're just like
I can't just go cuz I'll be offending
people but like no just yeah let's take
it back to making fun of dance later
yeah that was the story we were even
talking about oh another call of
pepperidge farm
let me get in there i'ma talk to dr.
Schneider also I think pepperidge farm
is like such a nice company do you know
any yeah like their commercials like
like when I was a kid like in this
goldfish it's like swim across the
street and I'd be like damn that's so
cute you know we're like my favorite
thing to do is when I got a goldfish
falls on the floor like when I'm eating
it and they put it in the toilet like it
died you're a huge loser why well when I
have to throw it away by just turning
the toilet cuz that's where goldfish go
but they're crackers they look like this
you know they're like just a cute
company actually the woman who owns my
apartment weirdoes for pepper beverage
farm Campbell Soup because when she
emails me um
her signature sells Campbell Soup and
she's like definitely really high up but
what's crazy is that Campbell Soup owns
Pepperidge Farm like you think it'd be
the opposite but like camels I guess
it's the bigger brand no Campbell's was
definitely around I didn't mean to make
sense after everything that Andy Warhol
did for them ya know they actually
seemed pretty equal to me Campbell's has
definitely been around for longer than
Campbell's just sounds more like a
product and pepperidge farm sounds like
a brand but you never know you never
it's pretty cool though now I want some
goldfish what's your favorite flavor um
I really like baked so they're not
cheddar II and they're not orange
they're like a little later they're
almost like a gold cult fish and they're
the blue bag and they're just like salty
crackers basically and they're so good
that's really good I love the mix of
cheddar and pretzel oh yes I cannot deal
with the dust the cheddar is so gross
and too like the bag that's like purple
and orange it's so ugly
yeah I do not like that brand I like I
find all goldfish are good but also
pepperidge farm is the Milano the best
cookie in the world and they make random
like sugar cookies they actually have a
great brand they have its electioned I
totally agree surprised many
a grocery store order on Peapod have you
not done it since the last one no
because I've been traveling so it's like
what's the point like you want to get
home yes totally and I'm so hungry all
the time
I understand boiled chicken in your
friend possibilities hit him with a wink
yeah okay and more brand news
Nike will just boost salaries this is
such a crazy story I know we suddenly
you're gonna change the stories like
this is boring this sporting brand will
raise salaries for more than 7,000
employees that's not that's cool and
adjust its bonus practices after
conducting an internal pay review the
move I'd like to make a more pay equity
they liked it a review and they saw that
they were in their corporate in ITT
corporate it's like these [ __ ]
elitist in corporations don't need more
money like give it to the real new
people the people who work in their
stores and work so hard on their meat
all day is he at the weenie who takes
meetings from computer do you know yeah
who escapes in like [ __ ] but the
move is the athletic apparel makers
latest attempt to achieve pay equity and
enhanced corporate culture for women
that's no it's nice it's nice I'm gonna
say to come me like Nike it must be hard
for women there Oh a hundred percent and
I'm very here for it but like this like
the same thing with the straws like this
is an important issue too but like let's
start like helping the people who work
so hard and like on the ground with
customers who just yell at them and they
trying all these different pairs of
shoes and if they have to put them back
yeah and they don't buy anything like
those are the people who need pay equity
not this woman who already is making
like 150 grand but like the guy next her
is making like 175 like she needs help
to 100% but like it's like she's the
straw and these people in the store are
the beer cans yeah but they need it
first yeah I know saying yeah I know
just a thought honestly mate did you see
that that big Nike town that's been
around forever on 57th between fifth and
six closed why it's like it was their
flagship it was like the most iconic
store it was in the shape of a
semicircle and it closed a while ago and
like no one really spoke about it and I
feel like it's like bad times for the
brand we drove past it with me and Ben
and he was like shook like he spent like
he grew up there like yeah we even went
yeah like it's like it was like FAO
Schwartz it was like a sort of tourist
destination it closed that's crazy
I know and so you wouldn't think they'd
just be boosting salaries left right
right you think they'd be making cuts
left and right right I don't know
think about it like Nike town sounds
off-brand for like the brand that it is
now which is just like Nike really just
do it and it could have changed it yeah
but I don't think they closed because
their name was Nike town no maybe
they're rebranding and also I mean it's
sad but it's also exciting to think what
might go in there you know into the
millage its should we buy it and do the
toast from there everything and then we
can have like a whole audience standing
outside would you guys love tons where
it'd be so much better you can come at
10 o'clock yes as opposed to four yeah
how much do you think that spaces like
to rent per month yeah like fifty
thousand dollars or more I never know
what things cost for the month so like
an apartment that's like a one-bedroom
in a big building is like four thousand
dollars yes so it's the whole building
building but it's not like a skyscraper
it's like three levels okay mm I think a
hundred thousand on 57th Street
wait also I had done it some research
and I reached out to this this man
because I really think we should get a
billboard somewhere and I was trying to
like get prices and this guy was giving
me like New York is too expensive I
think we should do one and like in
Boston or Chicago sure but like do you
know how much those things cost it's
like I know like if you get like a tiny
little thing
I'm like a pay phone it's like five
grand like for anything big it's like a
million but what if we were just two
guys three billboards outside I'm sorry
so I actually had spoken to the ebbing
Missouri billboard Commissioner
clearchannel yeah he said stop calling
we don't work here anymore but I like we
shouldn't share those go for a pretty
penny now yeah is ebbing Missouri a real
place yes
Missouri is just like oh my god I was
just in Missouri we're in Missouri
that's what I was saying I Michelle like
you don't consider st. Louis like now
Lewis was Louisiana no I'm like Satan
st. Louis is like lamb city on a rooftop
cosmopolitan Missouri is like cow
tipping like they're just not the same
no they're not the same and that sad
both story from Missouri is so sad it's
so terrible it's getting worse and
Saturn its and I was in Missouri but it
was happening and like not to make it
about myself but out there that's change
ya know it was like I explained your
ring today oh yeah by the way we have to
get through this we the guests keep oh
god okay um congrats Nike for like
paying your women equally like welcome
to the club yeah welcome to like you
shouldn't have have to put this out cuz
it's like embarrassing them 2018 you're
still not saying are we so quit
yes my house okay fifth and final story
from a source that we've never cited
before hello giggles a New York Times
critic body shamed a Broadway actress
and fans are not happy so I saw this
article on chenko from Blue Bloods I
call her an Instagram on her Instagram
story she was just like literally she
quoted the review and it was like so
disgusting and like the fact that more
people aren't talking about it it's like
upsetting so I took it upon myself to
talk about it um and some Nike town
updates it's moving to Fifth Avenue and
the property is worth a cool 235 million
holy [ __ ]
so maybe after a few more episodes we
can afford it ya know just one more
month of patreon and then we can do it
okay here's the story the spirit of
musical theater has been always one of
acceptance a place where people from all
walks of life can come together and
enjoy that's very true I went to a
musical theater SoulCycle last night and
it was so well musical theater is like
the epitome of just inclusion oh my god
he played this song NYC from Annie which
is just an underrated tongue to begin
with but there's a part where the
Rockettes are tap-dancing we were on our
bikes and it sounded like we were me all
the time it was so cute okay which is
why many are calling on in New York
Times theater critic who by lisheen
talented theater actress Alicia Empress
in a recent review in her review for the
off-broadway show Smokey Joe's Cafe
Laura Collins Hughes described many
elements of a woman yeah and I thought I
just imagined it was a man and it's not
Friday so if they're reviewing off
Broadway shows why aren't they reviewing
on Broadway shows yeah we're on Broadway
you're on Broadway
yeah including costume design this in
turn led her to write quote miss um
frisk by the way is bigger than the
other women on stage and the costume
designer elaha Viet II doesn't seem to
have known how to work with that
dressing her in an unflattering way he
does better with the skimpy yet not
ovary overly revealing pink fringe
outfit Emma Duggar stet wears and
jiggles in for the leering number teach
me how to shimmy the [ __ ] basically in
the review she's reviewing the costumes
and what she says is that the costume
designer didn't do a good job dressing
this woman because she's quote bigger
than the other ladies first I saw a
picture of this girl she's like the most
like normal-looking girl of all time
right yeah I'm saying yes she's like
literally the most average she
average-sized woman unlike the New York
Times's
always getting up everyone's asked about
like being politically correct so like
now I'm up your ass New York Times this
is so not fair also this girl's so
normal-looking I feel like when you
start to call like average looking
people like plus-sized or like comparing
them to just like some small people and
right why have we got to compare that's
like so dangerous like I'm sorry a size
6 or size 8 is in no means big like that
is so dangerous and just like your job
is not to comment on the bodies of the
actresses you were commenting on the
costumes so talk about the costumes not
the people wearing them I just thought
it was like so egregious that's a
perfect use of the word it's definitely
egregious we should all go see the show
and support it yes what's it called um
off Broadway Smokey Joe's Cafe sounds
kind of good a Smokey Joe oh yeah what's
this about Shelly Joe friends yes okay
you still haven't decided what episode
you're gonna make me watch in order to
convince me that it's not the worst show
of all time okay okay okay okay okay I
can't think right now but I will find it
yeah no I'm just telling you have
homework to do okay um so we are gonna
take a quick break and then when you're
gonna be back with Derrick path who is
from The Bachelorette that's from
Paradise recently single we're gonna get
them on here asking the tough questions
you know so we got a bunch of really
good question enough questions like will
you marry me yes we got a bunch of
really good questions on our Instagram
of Derrick but then also comment on the
Facebook or YouTube streams questions
you have for Derek and we will do our
best to get them to him
stay tuned for like four minutes we will
be back
you
we are back with the one the only dark
path the much talked-about dairy pet
thank you for joining about my time okay
nothing like we could I know just start
off your week with your uh with you Jim
Halpert America we could have cut it cut
off living like a classic Jim Pam
actually the bail I wore to my real
wedding oh and I haven't washed it since
so you could really still smell the
excitement
I'm so glad thank you so much for being
here
wow it's just such a coincidence when
you come to the show with is a day and
Claudia forgot her ring so I just step
away for this interview but I felt like
I needed to be here this is it to bring
some and family show yeah something fun
show someone needs to settle you kids
down okay welcome to the show
all jokes aside I'm so glad that you're
a year cuz I love you first show many
reasons and I was standing behind the I
know you didn't know I was there but I
heard you guys said I'm Jaggi really
made a good point like why everyone
loves you and I could tell you because
as someone who loves you I just think
you really got like the boot way too
early on your season with Georgia I was
so surprised when she should have gone
home on your to I'm sad and surprised
like everyone was like Derek's going
home like no how do you guys not see it
like he's not going off but sorry you
did go home and I just want to know hey
what was that like and B what is the
what do people tell you you look like
the most is it John Krasinski you really
look like that okay so one of my friends
growing up I think looks even more like
him than me I guess fate I guess facial
structures but but so once I can went on
the show like I've always loved the
office like a crazy a ton like that's
every night when I go to sleep
I'm like I skip season 1 because nobody
likes season 1 there you go but so right
away I was like oh my god this is kind
of amazing
least it's not why it yeah and it was
cute he's cute everybody everybody's
cute in their own way he kills it
actually the guy's hilarious
you know I I did run into oh now I came
to give his name the guy that plays Ryan
um yeah I beat you know back in the
streets here in the city one time and it
was just like he doesn't seem like a
nice guy is he he was busy yes okay no
so the 201 oh yeah
the weird thing was that like chase and
I didn't dislike each other usually
they're very like confrontational right
and so the whole time we were just like
this is the most awkward thing of all
time and then like a two-on-one but I
lost yeah you bet you know where my
roses going I dunno but we can say
friends and like you know do um each
other know that I'll leave that to you
sister but then so so I mean it was
really just like the most awkward time
on the whole show that that one day cuz
literally the whole day was like the
only limo and all of our Janina I think
too so when we were driving around there
was like 400 people outside they had no
they had no idea why that was like they
had to keep they did they had to keep
like driving around the block so not
yeah and then I got sent home and got
very drunk and cry don't cry for me
Argentina which is just honestly there
anything is annoying sometimes like that
was kind of fun it was an inspired
choice I mean I laughed it was yes you
have to be able to laugh at yourself or
some part of the franchise but then you
have like the ideal scenario and going
back to paradise not right now but like
what in the time you did happen yes
ideal scenario
um because I feel like paradise can be
like super treacherous just like the
conditions
totally was your season the Demario and
Chris yeah we had so what was the
shutdown like
from your perspective well alright so so
like the worst part about all of it is
not being able to be yourselves and just
hang out with each other and worry about
like oh what's the camera gonna pick up
and then they're gonna add it like that
you're not worried about what you're
saying necessarily we're like oh how
could they spin this that's like always
in the back yeah
so they they later they they turn all
the cameras off and we were just like
having a party for five days basically
it was very stressful
yeah did you think it was gonna pick
back up when you know oh yeah no nobody
thought at all there was no no no chance
did you fly home me
yeah I was well we that we were there
for five days because they're like we're
trying to figure this out with the law
right well yeah I flew home and I was
like back home in Iowa and so crazy are
you from Iowa um sort of yeah I did all
like I got you know lost my virginity
got quits a cop that's like what defines
who you are fifteen young a third guy
her boy actually yeah I was like dating
her that's nice literally were like two
days boring like two days apart oh my
god no she's it's Tomoka the one that
got away what is up no she's not
no it was very stressful at the end you
know like what I like
continue to process it all the time I
think that like she didn't want to leave
Seattle and she wants to like she wanted
to like travel here and travel there and
take advantage of some of this stuff and
it's kinda like we were talking about I
was just like like I I got my job here
right I have my like normal we trying to
thirst out for it yeah I don't want to
call her out for being too thirsty no
level of thirst ahead in this life and
the Bachelorette you so many
opportunities no you would be a fool not
to take them up for to go on like at
some point the jig is up and just like
move on go back to work like get a job
and you say great I'm like but you can't
just rely on to link up I'm not I think
Ravens due to intense about that stuff
yeah
as long as it's not on what do you do
I'm a banker
so what but hold on actually we do like
cool technology stuff anything that can
help us up it's probably yeah so wait
what is the word you use Millennials of
that we are the second biggest student
loan refinance er in the US and so yeah
it's like everyone is getting yeah good
over like constant like you can save
half of your interest rate so like
shouldn't be there anybody can literally
refinance and like save our average
customer saves $20,000 well what is your
remedy well for all of our Millennials
oh there you go so go to my Instagram
and click on the nice plug there's
actually and on top of that this is
actually just happened to work out you
if your loan closes you get $200 cash
back because you use my link link on my
two hundred dollars two hundred sales I
was like I changed I was like we belong
history we do so did you have that job
before the show yeah it's like done
various jobs yes similar thing okay so
back to Taylor sorry so you're Taylor
it's now hanging up a little you crazy
and yeah another ex of yours
not really that was a kid that was an
overplayed thing I was here in the city
we hooked up sex our hope making out
because it's very different both it
yeah it's both well which one did you
guys all it was all yeah the honest when
we talked like two weeks and then it was
like this isn't gonna like this isn't
what I want to do and certainly like I
texted back oh that's because no you're
not doing this one text but I was the
tener but to me I was like oh we're not
even dating this is just like a you know
we're feeling things out and I was like
no I'm not this is not the place of am i
right
so I guess that's fair but so when they
started hanging out was literally like I
was working were you were yeah I was
like working a lot that week and she
just like we like a couple days later
she's like oh hey just so you know like
Olivia's in town we hung out I was like
oh cool I'm glad that you guys like
caught up and maybe buried the hatchet
and she was like yeah and she's probably
gonna move into my building I was like
wait what so so they live literally like
a floor apart
and I was like all right now hold on
this is somebody the top magic
that's like it was so it was actually
like a not a part of like why we broke
up but it was it was like indicative of
like all right this is where this is
headed no no but it's I don't know so
when did you two officially break up
probably like a week before like that
announcement well did you feel did you
both feel extra pressure to like make it
work just so that you weren't like
another failed that's okay okay well I
think that's any anything that goes
without saying like if other people care
about it you're like no it's like really
try hard at this yeah
so that's kind of why I think at the end
it was very obvious that like they
needed to be yeah so how does a bachelor
breakup go like who do you have to tell
are they disappointed how long were you
engaged for she to get back her ring
yeah yeah she'd have to get back a ring
cuz I think it's three years you have to
be together seems fair seems fair yeah
so ours was very basic like I asked her
actually I was like well how do you want
to do it like I'm we're just gonna post
something on Instagram like Dean and no
yeah yeah they like and and then Claire
and Benoit right they just like posted
an Instagram post I mean in the end like
wanted to reach out to PR people and
just like do a blanket statement so that
it was just like one yeah I mean said I
was shocked I really was cuz like I
don't really love her but she made her
soft in paradise and then I was like I
like it's kind of cute but it's a tough
to date a mental health counselor she
always like analyzing
she's not but definitely like she thinks
different she's actually analyzing my
mental health and the whole like
emotional intelligence thing but is it
but is she like that for all sometimes
did you ever like drop the turn
emotional intelligence like not ironic
in everyday life yeah okay I'm like all
about that psychology stuff so we
actually so I totally yeah so would you
go back on bachelor in paradise winter
names whatever they do next I don't know
I'm like I have such a hangover from all
this snow right now I'd like I just I'm
trying to do my do my life and like get
back and actually live in the city
because I was traveling so much I was
like going to Seattle and then we went
going here and then we were going
there's literally like I would work five
days and then I would fly somewhere take
a red-eye back and like instantly start
again I was no she's come here for like
two or three weeks actually like but
that's just so weird like that's what
The Bachelor it's like you're getting
gaging you live together yeah you got an
agent you don't have the same person's
phone number that's like ours was unique
because we went home right alright so I
had even like FaceTime with her mom and
stop do you think your relationship
would have progressed as much as it did
without the shutdown probably not did
you guys connect before the shutdown and
then like we yeah this shutdown was
actually like very like again no cameras
so we could just talk about whatever we
wanted it was actually positive for the
worst thing about paradise worst thing
about paradise the crabs like actually
like actually crabs so you don't think
you know well we so do you remember Nick
benvenuti say the boss he is like you
know he's from I don't know where he's
like from the middle of nowhere in
Alabama
deep south so he absolutely so he was
like the crab whisperer he was like bit
late and then pick him up and then Raven
and I were like but they are like you
can't take a nap without the like end up
crawling in
yeah once it starts raining there there
there will be like hundreds of crabs on
the side that it's just it's like New
York in the summer yeah it's so [ __ ]
hot so if you were to go back on
paradise is there anyone that you would
be interested in anything from what's
your type mmm
absolutely
I like witty clever people so there you
go I don't know Taylor quippy and clever
no she but she's but she liked the other
aspect of that is somebody who's like
able to call me on my [ __ ] and be like
oh yeah and I like that I like somebody
who there's like a back and forth when
you have your eye on enfranchise any of
re girls here are great girls yeah you
did really pretty honestly like I
freaking love Becca I swear to god she's
engaged I don't care
would you okay say time lines were
reversed uh-huh would you have gone on
Becca season if they were about to start
filming next week like how Becca Tilly
did for Bennigan's sure cute if they
offered you the position on The Bachelor
I don't know about that that's a yeah
it's a lot think about like what I just
went through like I said it's a major
hangover imagine that times like a
thousand yeah right you're just like and
I you know I hung out with a couple of
those guys they can't like walk down the
street without people just all over the
place it's like it's so hiring on your
mental health that's why I like Taylor
Swift who do you think will be the next
Bachelor
I think it's gonna be this Blake guy you
do I think he's got like these different
layers and plus he's shown that like he
can kind of he's always anxious so I
think that could be fun to actually see
yeah somebody who you know he takes it
very seriously first of all and he's
constantly like I don't know what to
think about this I don't know what to
think about that and we've had too many
like a comb-over
actor bachelors Lee yes I agree you know
I mean and I think he can't help but
just like yeah we could use a little bit
of humanity yeah my receipt totally and
like maybe get rid of laptop and girl
yeah he'll have a glow yeah back I had a
great one yeah Saudi rich Lindsay so
Jojo yeah yeah she go up it's still
happening she looks different
please no it's a great face her face was
great her new face is great I love a new
face up are you guys like we hate
everyone pretty much I like Raven and I
love Alexis
we love Tennant love Corinne I don't
know I just don't know I don't feel like
I the same thing like I didn't give
enough he's just always like he's very
pretty yeah captions but he just follow
me on Instagram so like I'll live you
know yeah you might be being replaced
Sarah but then know the rumors do you
think there's a chance he would be a
bachelor have you heard any old name I
don't think so I just again I think he's
too like he's not like interesting
enough for the camera because you're in
the know do you know who the bouncer is
gonna be before most people you find out
with everyone else no literally like so
remember my season was Kayla and Jojo
they were like oh who's it gonna be
they even like film that Kayla's how
savage is bad so sad she really thought
she was gonna be it but they're never
like self or Jojo
because they felt so bad for her yeah
and like she's just like way cute so she
got the boot and like I we were all
literally sitting in the hotel room they
tell like five people like nobody knows
the actual person Bobby yeah but you
know who wins right like a friend yeah I
know right yeah
that's that's all that's been ruined
yeah so do you still watch the show yeah
you do I do just to make fun of it yeah
makes it so easy when you look at it
from like a sarcastic guy it's like the
best time ever and you know why it like
you know better than anyone and you have
to it's like what we said before you
have to be like able to make fun of
yourself along with it cuz yeah it's a
weird goofy thing like gays laugh at
yourself don't take yourself too
seriously yeah
so anybody on the bachelor bachelorette
if you guys are not laughing at yourself
yeah
is that a sponsor watch
I knew it what's your code I'm just
trying to get more sponsors do you get
like a lot of dates in your dams or like
on Instagram so alright
I never expected people to be because
like the DM z-- were thirsty before
mm-hmm
they're open again yeah she knows you
know yeah that's actually the reason why
tail and I broke up was because climb
and I started the I mean game I always
said could tell that she was threatened
you know just like her they've I bet I
got but no we all knew but I gather
nobody ever sent anything it was like
very nice like the face respect it was
ever met someone in real life totally
yeah yeah do you take them out to dinner
you just upset to them no I don't just
have sex with them I want to meet drinks
it alright but think about this you know
sketchy that is like the disease is
you're much more protective I am of the
DM people it's like no we're gonna like
it's gonna be like eight dates before so
that I know you're not like trying to
just be thirsty for followers screen
capture and my text messages so what's
your criteria for going out with someone
who DMC like one of our followers are
definitely gonna go in your damsel yes
we have an emotional smart like just
great I feel like you could find your
wife yeah which would be really sad for
me but I'd also be happy for you guys
and if it was a toaster and like we
could be a family affair that would be
more than enough for us what are you
looking for tell us I am again I like I
like somebody that can give it back to
me as much as cuz I'm a very I'm a
pretty sarcastic person I like pretty
dry humor to do like something that
can't take that exactly that's like my
honestly tomorrow same time
yes you know so you never know if
someone's joking yeah you know whether
to laugh or like cry you're sick that's
what like wells is my best friend now
like actually in real life have you met
Sarah Hyland yeah what do they like
together they're like the cutest
feelings for selfishly disgustingly cute
together yeah it's that's so cute I
didn't work I wanted him I wanted to be
like
I'm protecting you from this yeah -
sarah hyland have any famous friend she
wants to introduce you to maybe who's
your celebrity crush so I feel like it's
called the doubt I don't know why I
don't like because that's like Becca
vibes yes a woman actually do I know
Jerry this is like before we were saying
when somebody asks you like oh say
something 100%
I have watched Wonder Woman no joke eyes
but no she's like a strong woman and she
looks like that guy like aesthetically
true that's gonna yeah I like the
brunette yeah skin it's an olive skin
tone olives I'm olive I'm half Brazilian
so are you yeah
which half my mom she's born there do
you go back can you miss everything
twist do you want to wear the veil [ __ ]
wait back to of what you look for in a
girl someone who didn't give it back
yeah I mean the mental is really far
more important there's like lots of
different forms of what is beautiful so
I'd like I'm not really specific on that
I've dated like tiny little blonde women
and like very tall you know targets
cogito yeah yes exactly mental health
counselor is like whatever on Taylor's
podcast a couple times yeah what how
many people listen to it I'm just so
curious no she has actually a pretty
good following yeah what are you
thinking about post bachelor podcasts
would you ever do one because you really
are carrying yourself quite well well
okay so what do you ask I'm here to
promote actually that's why I wasn't
gonna say anything okay no um the
company betches thing like I'm pretty
close with a few of the girls there and
they've asked me to like temporarily
test host their bachelor like if they
have really good podcast yeah and
they're like totally into that sarcastic
tone - yeah so I can just like great
pairing absolutely so where you live I
mean stay
I heard you guys talking that's whoa
which is another X Factor just talking
and then telling me a loud sound if you
can say where he lived and I heard you
tell him where we live down I'm never
gonna know now you know but he's in New
York in the city like we're not in the
city I'm gonna city like four days a
week
that's how yeah and how many dates we
could you go on I haven't I've been on
like one date since I was yeah if I was
even in Sanford
I don't know except don't really think
I've tried right you know I'm like I'm I
did I did that and honestly like
hangover still I'm still trying to
figure out like that's a perfect way to
put it a hangover yeah he's like yeah I
can push through it probably yeah then
once you're done with the hangover like
you're ready to drink again totally we
can look at that would you want paradise
I don't know paradise is like sighs it's
like that's true though but like it's
also the most it's not it's the opposite
of paradise
yeah do you really have like the most
ideal scenario so for you to say that it
was still treacherous like you got there
and okay like zero stress I was like oh
yeah right here the whole time we're
still under a lot of pressure and you're
like a man you do your hair right I
can't even imagine what it's like for a
girl to be on that show like I would
never you couldn't pay me ten million
dollars to do it really today on TV with
like delivering the Jenna feed with
frizzy hair and everything sweet goodbye
the Webern is it you're there like okay
get ready for the rose ceremony and
you're like super hot and somebody you
shower and you get out and you're just
like super hot all the boys are told you
read to this shirt is a completely
stuffed in the bag it's so good
my favorite was Robbie actually because
his like hair wouldn't do what he was
right long thick hair that's all I can
think about I'm like their next must be
just like so sweaty but those who are
both just like tiny and seriously
beautiful yeah ya gotta be I was like
drunk the first night and I remember
that was like Raven can I talk to you
and I was so I was so like over lying
like you're so the most beautiful girl
now we're like super close friends yeah
where you went from paradise who were
you hoping to me actually Raven yeah
sing I'm hope save or even still I tried
to make out with her and she was on the
show oh yeah you know I tell everyone
that I like pretty girls that I want to
get some on the lips like yeah Upton I
think in same it was some girl came up
to me that's like where's your phone
don't take pictures she's like no I just
want to talk my god that's so nice
can I get a little this student becomes
the teacher is like no touch your hair
and I was like oh my god really did you
learn a lesson like I'm gonna stop doing
it oh hell no if I ever meet Kate Upton
I'm asking her fair I'm sure she gets it
a lot um chief a questions for us yes
will you go to lunch with me yes and I
feel like Jack and I could really find
you like the perfect girl someone we're
not threatened by totally and then we
can all just remain friends yeah and
then the continuous I like the drama we
like yes Prince from college the Netflix
show no okay so yeah all these friends
from college yeah there's like a couple
there's two couples and then like 10
years later like they're all like having
kids and like things get crazy because
like some of them start
cross-pollination enemy us and then and
you and whoever perfect Ben will like
you meet you I want to meet him yeah you
should I'll bring lunch maybe double in
on um thank you so much for being here
thanks for thanks for having everybody
yeah Thank You toaster he's very getting
Derek we need to do that now with like
Kim Kardashian yeah it was so should we
attack next let's tell everyone
whoa Kelly Clarkson no yeah so much like
someone realistic like someone who like
is in New York a lot okay who do we want
to hear from I mean how do you think
nobody I only here to listen to
ourselves totally we'll think about it
I'm climbing up the job depth in Kate
Upton okay everyone go comment on Kate
Upton's Instagram we want you on the
chose at the morning shows like a
million times
hey should we meet what she's in New
York ya know cuz I thought was a small
toast
yeah toast the Kate Upton at the morning
toast thank you guys so much for coming
Thank You Derek for being here anyway
when I dress up with us we will be back
tomorrow with
just another wonderful show for you will
be having Real Housewives of Orange
County cause Jackie to not do her
homework and didn't watch and I did and
I just want to say in the first episode
I didn't see Emily's husband and then
this episode when she said he's half
Persian half Mormon I was like afraid of
what he was gonna look like
but he's actually not cute so good for
her also she looks like she's Jesse
she's Jesse from and we won't be calling
her anything other than chess if Jesse
says I can't remember her name
yeah I can't believe her name is Emily
this whole time I thought it was like
Lisa you know or like Gina Gina she is
Jeana Keough reincarnated we're back
tomorrow 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time make
sure to like us on facebook at the
morning toast youtube the morning toast
that's where we go live but if you're a
podcast aren't enough time to enjoy the
beautiful set and our fake palm trees
make sure to subscribe to us in the
podcast app at the morning toast we'll
see you tomorrow morning
peace out
you